[Music]
I stayed on at Stanford after graduating
- I've taught for most of the past 25
years at the School of Medicine teaching
wellness and meditation and happiness
and poetry and things that are hard to
believe that Stanford would pay for I
remember the first time it was in 2009
that my teaching partner and I started
the happiness class at Stanford and I
remember first about how difficult it
was to get any department to let us be
within a hundred miles of their class
offerings offering something unhappiness
I remember like the psychology
department thing well what is happiness
have to do with psychology and ok and
the hum bio department and the School of
Education well we can't we can't foster
anything like that and the director of
Aden at that time said well wait a
second I think this is good for our
students so I will simply use my name as
a like a full professor in the medical
school so we offered believe it or not
the happiness class out of the
department of pediatrics for its first
like X number of years and the campus
because that was the only place that
would take us but the first class I
remember this clearly just how peculiar
it was to be asking you know kind of
hyperactive 18 and 19 year olds to like
sit still and contemplate the bounty and
blessing of their life to actually sit
and reflect upon how unbelievably lucky
they are to be at Stanford University -
to not just be in the future with what
this education will bring but to bring
it in you know - to sit with like how
the heck is it possible in a world of 7
billion people that I got lucky enough
to be sitting in this room at this time
at this school so one of the first
practices that we did in do to remind
people of how lucky they her to be at
Stanford is we send them outside to take
a walk for a little bit around campus
and appreciate the natural beauty of the
environment like that that's an actual
class exercise like get up put your
phone down apologize to your phone for
leaving it tell your phone you promise
you'll be back and then go outside
quietly and reflect on just how
beautiful it is not how much you have to
do not how important you are not what
you're gonna do in the future not all of
the need based drives that we have that
dominate us but a simple quiet walk
reflecting upon what it feels like for
the breeze hit your arm here in Northern
California or hell direct and gorgeous
the Sun is and just enjoy you know enjoy
for a few minutes the gift of this so
the first time we did this we sent him
out for like I don't know 10 minutes
thinking how many of them are gonna come
back you know how good you know
and what are they gonna say so when we
one week when they came back we kidded
with them and said you know if any of
you speak to your parents tonight
like the likelihood is if they say so
what do you do in school today and you
tell them that some teacher sent you
outside to stare at trees they may be a
little concerned about where their
tuition dollars are going and yet as I
as I've gotten more into this question
of happiness I'm struck more and more
deeply about that's probably one of the
handful of few actual questions that
might really matter to us how do we
become happy like how do we take this
gift of our life this short confusing
mysterious gift and how do we live it in
a way that we can say with most of it
thank you you know thank you for the
opportunity to be here thank you for the
experiences thank you at some very deep
level for the capacity to learn how it
is we navigate this place and thank you
for the intelligence aspiration whatever
it is to try to figure it out
thank you but most of us don't do this
most of the students here don't do this
most of the adults here don't do this
most people don't do this they they they
don't take just this staggering mystery
question like what is life what are we
here for what can we do here to make it
meaningful they don't bring that in
deeply enough and so if you don't
bring that question in deeply enough
it's very hard to say thank you for the
opportunity to try to live that answer
you know what is this life for and why
am I here
and and what was I created to do you
know I think being a X kind of late 60s
early 70s hippie I think all the time
about Abraham Maslow's pyramid and I now
teach like another generation of
students that simple elegant description
of what are we here for like what is it
that motivates us and it's as relevant
today as it was when I first discovered
it maybe in 1970 in a high school
psychology class as to like how much of
our time do we want to spend at the
bottom of that pyramid like one that one
of the great I'm gonna say failures of
Stanford students more than I would like
to see is in their determination and
their Drive and their like massive
amount of energy they spend getting to
this school they don't they've lost some
of their wonder and some of their
curiosity about okay yes I can be
successful I can become a physician or I
can make them a lot of money in business
or whatever I can do but why and what's
the benefit and to whom well we're all
struggling with that you know we're all
in enough of a hurry we're all affluent
at least the people in a room like this
well all affluent enough not to have to
worry about many things
we haven't thought deeply enough about
life to recognize the necessity of
climbing that pyramid in terms of what
it is we wake up to in the morning you
know and and and the most brilliant part
of Maslow's work is the part that's
probably least known so most of you
learned probably in high school and then
in a psych one class in college of the
pyramid you know that at the bottom
level of the pyramid is first safety
needs so food clothing shelter sex
whatever the most basic needs are that's
the strongest motivation that human
beings have then right above those are
the survival needs right above that of
the safety needs such as okay I have
food now how do I make sure I'll have it
tomorrow or next week or next month I
have a roof over my head but how do I
make sure that roof will be there in a
month or six months or a year so that
survival and safety needs the two
brilliant things that Maslow elucidated
about happiness were no matter how well
no matter how often no matter how deeply
you meet those needs they will never
make you happy that is a such a powerful
challenge to almost any culture that
exists on this earth that no matter how
well you survive and no matter how safe
you are that in and of itself will never
make you happy that just sets the
conditions for which you can begin to
actually explore happiness and and I and
I want to make that abundantly clear
that most of the time
survival and safety or necessities for
going up the ladder to actually confront
happiness but our world has conflated
survival and safety with happiness that
we have been taught and almost all of us
have bought the kool aid that surviving
like you know making sure that you and
the people you love survive is an
ultimate value rather than just a
necessary step for the actual deeper
truths to emerge then being safe which
is also absolutely essential
so having money in the bank having
physical health having enough
possessions having enough entertainment
having enough protection against the
elements that too is necessary for
happiness but only as a precondition
having money in the bank taking a
vacation to France instead of Monterey
those don't contribute to happiness what
they do is they're buffers against
anxiety and they're buffers against the
existential angst and anomie that
paralyze people and we're taught very
deeply and very strongly all over the
place that those safety needs like
having you know ten times what you need
in the bank or earning 20 times more
than the people at the bottom of the
food chain somehow that will make you
happier
starting with Maslow and 25 years of
research show that it's not so it's not
that having more
and being able to vacation in France or
Bali make you less happy
they just make nothing to do with
whether you're happy they're
epiphenomenon for happiness but the
thing that Maslow distinguished which is
so powerful besides the fact that safety
and survival are not happiness is he
postulated and this is not taught to
most undergraduates is that we actually
have two separate need pathways we have
deficit needs and something he refers to
as meta needs we have deficit needs such
as on the whole practice of his pyramid
the deficit needs are I need to survive
I need to have shelter and food and
everything else I need that because I
don't have enough I need safety because
I'm not safe enough I need relationships
because I'm lonely I need esteem because
I'm empty
I need beauty to fill my space but what
he postulated that's just so powerful is
that human beings have meta needs or
sufficiency needs as well as deficit
needs and this is where you start
getting sketchy with most dominant
cultures which are teaching us how to
meet our deficit needs through the
vehicle of the culture but the meta
needs are different the meta needs are I
need to be the kind of person that other
people get comfort from that's a a meta
relationship
I need to be stable so other people can
depend on me I need to create
relationships in this world so I can
give those are meta relationship needs
there are esteem needs such as I feel
great that I was given an award because
it recognizes my good work so I feel
better about me that's a wonderful
deficit
esteem need but we have meta needs which
is to feel good because we've simply
helped because we've added a little more
beauty to this world that we have made a
contribution or that we have grown in a
way that is beneficent is generous not
arising out of deficit we also have what
Maslow called like beauty understanding
knowledge a whole ethereal set of needs
which is you can read and learn and
study to gain something which is
graduate school which is great but you
can read and learn and study to become
in awe of this world we inhabit which is
a meta need the deficit need is
absolutely essential but happiness more
emerges when we're able to touch the
metal part of the need as well so
learning because learning is fantastic
going to a museum or climbing a mountain
not just to say you've been there like
the the kind of tourist thing yeah I've
been to the Louvre
you know I've climbed ever
that's a deficit need a Metin need is I
go because it gives me a chance to touch
the unbelievably profound beauty that
human beings and this earth have created
and it's not about nourishing the
separate me it's about opening up to a
bigger something that I'm a part of and
I feel most full when I recognize the
absolute remarkable experience that I'm
entitled to visit for a while and Maslow
postulates that the last need or
self-actualization is an arising from a
place where you've touched each of the
needs below it and the wonderful thing
about self-actualization from Maslow is
it's not that there's a predetermined
end point
it's that each one of us has a distinct
and unique path through this life that
nobody else has and the self actualized
Drive which is what pushes all the other
drives is to try to take this life to
figure out what your unique contribution
to it is for some people it's
relationship for some people it's
learning for some people its esteem you
know it's that giving esteem for some
people it's creating safety it's not the
same for each of us but the brilliance
of Maslow was that he mentioned even in
the 60s that
the handful of people who get to that
self-actualized place they are mostly a
cultural they step out of the majority
of the people in their culture because
they take the risk to march to their own
drum but he was very clear in
understanding that they wore an anti
cultural they wore rebellious and they
wore in hostile they were inner directed
and that they knew they couldn't do what
everybody else did or what the the base
line was because that would inhibit
their ability to live the one as Mary
Oliver said what the one wild and
precious life that we all have what are
we going to do with that so when I have
been teaching happiness classes here and
giving talks all over the place on it
the basic orientation is that question
like what am I gonna do what are any of
us gonna do with our one wild and
precious life and that's a very hard
question to answer it's made even more
difficult when all of us don't know the
research on what it is that makes people
happy so the the great thing about
teaching happiness classes now is that
there finally is some research there
when we started there was less than
twenty years ago there was very little
and now there's some and the essence of
the research unhappiness is that it
depends mostly on three things one that
you focus more on people
than things that you focus more on
people than money and that you focus
more on people even than acquiring now
what that means for most people is that
they do their things or acquiring with
other people so they have found that in
cultures that have family and shared
meals the act of actually sharing the
meal and you know family style
leads to an increase in happiness for
everybody who's a part of that so it's
not that you just have to do people but
we have a I'm gonna say a business ethic
which has instructed most of us to feel
that our economic lives are way more
important than our interpersonal lives
that it makes sense to sacrifice people
for economics that it makes sense to
sacrifice people for the value of buying
things and having material rewards
because we have been taught that things
and status which are wonderful our
mediators to happiness that when we have
enough things and when we have enough
influence then we'll be happy we're
taught that it's a mediator the problem
is that if you practice unhappiness
while you're going towards the mediator
so like if you work too much or you
ignore your kids because you're too busy
then you were practicing qualities that
train your brain in patterns of
unhappiness it's a very it's a very
challenging dialectic
but the key finding is that at the end
of your days and they've come at this
from two things one over the last 20 or
30 years they've interviewed many many
many dying people people in hospice
people with terminal illnesses and some
of you have seen that where they have
asked people what are your regrets and
you know the colloquial thing is that
nobody wish they had spent more time at
the office but when they asked people
what their regrets were people who were
dying or at the end or in hospice they
mentioned a few things one they
mentioned they didn't have enough fun
two they mentioned that I had lost track
of my friends that I got too busy and I
got too distracted and many of my
precious friends drifted away and three
they wished that they had spent a little
more energy and time giving to their
families giving a Maslow metta need
giving to their families those were the
top three having more fun not losing
track of friends and giving more within
the family the other data point that is
reaching that in in a similar way and
many of you cuz you know this oh the
stanford reunion so you're all well
educated and smart as many of you have
seen either the TED talk or the data on
that 80 year Harvard study that they
that they began in the 30s and they
followed two years of Harvard sophomores
for their lives and then the Harvard
people was so engaged in the study that
they followed their children and their
grandchildren so they now have
80 years worth of data and as successful
as Harvard people were and are as much
as they accomplished the two times that
they have fully analyzed the data and
revealed it publicly back in the 70s the
first time that this data was discussed
the psychiatrist who revealed the data
was somewhat and he didn't know what to
do with it
because it was Harvard and he had
trouble explaining culturally he wrote a
book but he had trouble explaining
culturally that in the school that had
the highest rates of success cultural
and material success for the United
States the element that most was aligned
with happiness
was relationship how happy were you with
your relationships how much time did you
spend with your relationships
was it a reciprocal giving of
relationship that contributed more they
re additive or followed the cohort for
another 40 years and just recently in
about 2015 they had another you know
social unveiling of this and this time
the psychiatrist because he he already
had the original data of relationship
this time he was even more both specific
and chagrined because the data showed
that the two the one and a half or two
qualities that most predicted happiness
were the ability to give and receive
love
and that's quite telling that you know
from from convergent data relationships
and love appear to be the underpinning
of what a happy and successful life
actually is you know one of the things
that I read years ago and since I do
teach here and I have some of that a
professor kind of interest which is I
love finding like silly streams of
studies that have no meaning and just
remember them to be able to say it talks
because you know studies contradict each
other they're small but I remember one
study from not that long ago which was
looking at business success and it was
only looking at men and maybe this is 15
years ago I can't remember but they were
trying to figure out and and this is why
science is both wonderful and ludicrous
they tried to figure out if getting a
promotion at work led men to want to
have more sex like didn't make them feel
more studly did it throw testosterone
you know now that they were the king of
the heap and the answer was yes for
about three weeks and then they went
back to the same old guy that they were
but they took married men so they had a
reliable sexual partner and they just
wanted to see did getting a promotion at
work lead them to more you know whatever
macho you know testosterone and it
lasted three weeks and then the human
tendency to take for granted what you
have took over the human tendency to
normalize and stabilize and become
inured to what you have took over
our brains are wired so that about 85%
of our neuronal connections are designed
for stability about 15% are designed for
newness so the 85% is to make sure you
go to work you do what you're supposed
to do every day you don't have to sit
there thinking about what do I do with
the pencil do I sharpen it or sticking
in my ear you know what to do with the
pencil because the majority of your
brain is designed for stability and a
kind of homeostatic experience right
you have 15% of your brain which gets a
lot of play now is neuroplasticity you
do you have a part of your brain that
can learn adapt and change but that part
of your brain is designed to be 15% it's
not designed because you'd go crazy if
you responded to all new situations and
stimuli without a stable pattern
underneath it the problem is that 80 or
85 percent makes us miss much of our
life it makes us take for granted much
of our life it dis allows us the
capacity to sit as these Stanford
students sit and not recognize how
unbelievably lucky we are it forces us
to not acknowledge that being able to
sit in a room like this with your body
comfortably breathing with your mind
functioning is an unbelievably gift that
will end the 85 percent has
take stuff in the best way for granted
but to be happy you have to keep some
edge on that unfortunately most of us
use the cellphone as that edge that we
use that to satisfy the part of us that
goes for newness and stimulation and
easily grasped interest instead of going
deeper and looking at what is it that we
really want to grow how is it that we
really want to unfold in our lives and
how is it at a minimum we can be like
not just happy but content with what we
have and not take it for granted so
happiness is a couple of different
streams
it's the pyramid thing of Maslow's
hierarchy of needs and it's a present
centered kind of awareness of what am i
doing what are my values and what is it
about my life right this moment that's
rich and important so I'm gonna I want
to do a few practices because if I just
yak for an hour it doesn't it doesn't
get in but I want to do a couple
practices with you with my time that
will help you understand one what
happiness is it's a presence centered
experience on an appropriate path
towards greater wholeness and growth
that would be my encapsulation of it
it's a positive presence centered
experience and appreciation of you being
on your appropriate road to your own
self actual as
that sounds really fancy that
unfortunately that's one of the costs of
teaching at Sanford you don't sound like
a normal human being but it's this
endless and the link of this before I
ask you to do some practices which is
the theme of the talk that I offered to
give is the relationship between
happiness and stress Albert Schweitzer
gave the best definition of happiness
that I've ever seen it's one thing what
you have this is a brilliant man of
course he didn't teach at Stanford
because he would have turned that into a
four paragraph thing because it had to
be published you know like all that
nonsense wanting what you have which is
only in the present which is only now
one thing what you have wanting who you
are loving who you're with as best you
can being happy what my tiny little
contribution to that is I added and
stress occurs when you want anything
else but what you have that's what
stresses you need stress you can't just
stay at comfortable and homeostatic you
need stress you need to strive you need
to grow you need to argue with your
environment you need to create change
you need to problem solve the problem is
most of us have too much stress and not
enough wanting what we have in fact many
of us believe that if we want what were
have we're going backwards
that's such a mistaken experience
because that's the only time that
you're happy is wanting what you have
within a framework of growth toward
self-actualization happiness is one
thing what you have stress is wanting
something else we need stress here's the
other problem and then I'm gonna give
you the couple of practices in our
current culture of hurrying everywhere
of always being in a rush your brain
under the quality of hurry is simply
stressed you might say I'm in a hurry
your brain and nervous system take it as
you're in danger
because the only reason you wouldn't be
enjoying your life is because there's
danger let's say your nervous system
interprets it like why would this person
be rushing around when it's a beautiful
day and there's people they love okay
there's got to be something really wrong
here
rushing and multitasking are signs to
your nervous system that things are not
okay so when you're on your phone and
doing something else which we all are
our nervous system takes it as if we're
in a difficult situation for us and that
it releases adrenaline to help us handle
the conflict and the stress it's one of
the reasons why you see so few people
looking genuinely content because very
few of us are not rushing or
multitasking and when you're rushing and
multitasking it's impossible to say I'm
happy with what I have because those are
both signs of not being happy with what
you have because you wouldn't be doing
that so the challenge is to find moments
of practice where you're happy with what
you have so I'm going to give you one of
those moments of practice if you'll all
please close your eyes
and sit comfortably for a moment
very gentle gently relax your breathing
and allow yourself to enter the
mind/body experience where you could
even begin to be happy which means
you're quieter you want your breathing
to relax and stabilize which doesn't
mean you can't be doing things we're
just doing this as a practice but you
want to quiet and slow your breathing
and you want to gentle your breathing
make it gentler this is because your
nervous systems basic omnipresent
question is are you safe and if your
nervous system can't answer that you're
safe you can't be happy so when your
belly relaxes and your breathing deepens
then your mind can start to entertain
positive loving beauty base thoughts
because your nervous system is in a safe
mode so you want to practice maybe two
or three slow deep breaths
where your nervous system is relaxed and
gentle
and then you want to bring an image to
your mind of someone you dearly love you
want to bring an image to your mind of
someone you dearly love and you want to
try to hold that image in a way that you
feel the love you have
and you want to relax into that
open-hearted sense of fullness and just
for a moment remember why this would be
the more you can experience this would
be the closer you get to a successful
life the more you can feel this as a
present centered experience of your life
let that go take a deep breath and
gently allow your eyes to open
and so I'm gonna give you another
practice what I'd like you to do is let
me let me explain the caveat first human
beings on average spend between 75 and
80 percent of their day complaining I
don't know what's funny about that but
it's it's true but that's what the
research suggests and that's because of
the tremendous negativity bias that our
brain has I I do some of these kind of
practices with people at work I mean I
work for a couple of companies that have
me come in and teach their people how to
be a little more happy because the bad
news and good news is that people who
are happier tend to be more productive
that overtime stress wears you out not
encourages you to do your best even
those short-term it's phenomenal but
what I'd like you to do since we live in
a brain world of 85 percent complaining
or 75 percent I'd like you to turn to
somebody near you and talk about what's
one part of the work you do no matter
how you define that work it could be
employment it could be volunteer could
be cleaning your house what's one part
of the work you do that you absolutely
love and why and I want you to talk
about it with no complaining at all
which is almost impossible for human
beings I my way of describing it as I
think root canal is easier than this for
people because we want to complain and
all over the place I'm asking you
to spend a few minutes describing one
part of your work in positive terms what
you love about it and only talk about
the positive part about it because the
way most of us are is well at work I
love the creative part except every 15
minutes my boss comes in and
you do something useful none of that
because if you're gonna be happy you
have to create the brain pathways that
recognize happy so quieting down opening
to love a happy pathway speaking with
deep conviction about what you love a
happy pathway you need to practice these
you need I mean again if I had a whole
day but you need to practice creating
environments like this at the work you
do so that people have more of their
brain to bring to their job if we just
have threat based parts of our brain and
scarcity base parts of our brain then
we'll do good work but if we bring the
meta needs to work if we bring the
abundance parts of ourselves if we bring
the desire to be kind and helpful to we
have much more real estate appear to
bring to work which is how happy people
are more effective they're hearty ER and
they're less they're more stress hardy
anyway please find somebody to have this
conversation with for a few moments
thank you
I wanna I want to just finish with just
one or two thoughts about this in the
research one of the things that really
distinguishes happy from less happy
people is so da that it's embarrassing
it's I know you
I'm sure the NIH needed a two million
dollar grant for this but happy people
actually wake up in the morning and
think what can I do to have a better day
less happy people wake up in the morning
and think I have so much crap to do so
there's the world's wisdom boiled down
right there for you but recognize again
and I'll and I will end this that within
a pyramid of needs values and
perspective you want to always be aware
of the rising nature the need for you to
ascend that pyramid over time for the
full flourishing of your humanity the
second piece is also to remember day by
day moments where everything about your
life is as it should be and that you're
thankful for what you have not just
acquiring what you don't like that's
that's such a simple but challenging
thing to remember what you have not just
bent on acquiring what you don't have
anyway I thank you for your time
[Applause]
[Music]